the success of Tomorrow starts with the
decisions of today I'm Bill Bernett the
executive director of the life Design
Lab at Stanford and I'm excited to
introduce you to a program that will
transform the way you think about
Innovations and their impact it's called
the emerging Technologies designing
strategy and forecasting disruption
program and if you're involved in
crafting your organization's strategy
this program is Catered for your success
now the program isn't just about
learning design is a contact sport it's
about doing with the opportunity to
visit Stanford's cuttingedge research
labs and apply the knowledge you learn
in lectures through immersive design
challenges which will give you a better
understanding of how Innovation is
fostered in areas like AI chat gp4 and
in human robotic interactions but
there's more than just the knowledge
you'll gain it's also about the amazing
people you'll meet from CTO to
entrepreneurs and your cohort to our
distinguished faculty at the Forefront
of research and innovation in their
Industries you'll connect with people
who have not only studied the tech
landscape but are actively shaping it by
the end of the program you won't just
understand Innovation you'll have lived
it and forecasted for your own company
the 5year Journey of Technology into the
future so I hope you'll join us for this
transformative journey and gain the
skills and knowledge needed to
confidently lead your organization into
a future where emerging Technologies
Drive success
[Music]